when night falls in southern portugal
it's time for mauricio nogueira to head
out to sea
the fisherman is heading for his fishing
grounds two nautical miles off the coast
of villarreal to santo antonio
there he will catch octopus like many
here in the algarve
my great grandfather grandfather and
father fished octopus as well
and my brothers too you need to have it
in your blood
it's a tough profession the ocean takes
everything out of you
strong winds and high waves make the
work difficult tonight
the 44 year old fisherman is committed
to the traditional way of catching
octopus
he sinks clay pots into the sea with a
rope and uses a winch to lift the pots
out of the water
in sum there will be an octopus hiding
this way of fishing is just fairer the
octopus goes into the clay pot to sleep
and can swim out at any time
fish traps on the other hand are just
traps
but fish traps are being used more and
more often
mauricio believes this is one of the
reasons why there are fewer and fewer
octopuses in the region
40 years ago there were no traps just
clay pots
my father tells me that in those days
they were octopi
all year round today more and more clay
pots are being replaced with traps
and some nights i hardly catch anything
[Music]
santa lucia is the algarves octopus
fishing hub
and the fishermen know all the fishing
methods inside out
joaquin oliveira has opted for traps
with bait inside
the 57 year old says it's more efficient
and convenient
because the traps can also be retrieved
during the day
the octopus goes in here and can't get
out
one meal until 2000 i also worked with
clay potts
then i switched to fish traps because it
makes for less hard work
fishing is easier and you just catch
more
[Music]
mauritsu can hardly keep up with the
fisherman's yields from their traps
even tonight his catch was small
compared to theirs
just 50 octopus or 70 kilos
yet the demand is on the rise year for
year
but octopus fishing is changing there
are more traps
and more plastic the traditional clay
pots are being replaced with plastic
containers
is a marine biologist at algarve
university
she's worried about this development and
points out that the oceans are already
full of microparticles
she tries to promote sustainability and
has one project with local fishermen
around 27 of all plastic that
is in the sea comes from lost gears or
or fishing devices so
there's there's there's a huge problem
there with those
these spots and with other fishing gears
that get lost and they're made of
plastic material
mauricio goes out fishing again the next
night
he has to hurry up to get the last
octopi before they wake up and swim out
of the containers
and he also once again has to repair a
rope that's been cut
deliberately the rope is broken because
another fisherman cut it
they don't respect my space i occupy a
large area with my clay pots
and that annoys the others
there is a lot of competition and it's
tough for him on the market and at sea
but maurizio wants to keep to his old
methods
even if that means he has to stay out
until the early morning hours
if you work hard and you're skillful you
can earn decent money in a month
you have to put up with the cold and the
bad weather
but you can make a pretty good living
he believes that his method is more
sustainable and hopes that it will one
day be required in the algarve
so that the sea is protected
you